The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So good
afternoon, everybody.
You see the topic
for today's class
on the screen--
entangled photons.
Just to remind
you, when we talked
about single photons and
Mach-Zender interferometers,
we realized that when we have a
nonlinear interferometer where
one mode, you can say one
beam, affects the phase shift
in the interferometer
for the other photon.
Then we get a
nonlinear situation,
and we can create photon states
which no longer factorize.
So we have a system
a, a system b,
and we can no longer write
down the total wave function
in a wave function for
system a times system b.
And this is something
very interesting,
and this is what we
feature in this section.
So we finished the last class
by defining entanglement.
And just to remind you, we
said something is entangled
if it is impossible to write
it in a product of two wave
functions.
So therefore, if you have some
correlation between the two
systems, then we
call the two systems
and the state of the
system entangled.
Now this is a definition
which needs explanation,
so we went through
some examples.
And we showed that certain
states which on first sight
look entangled
are not entangled,
because if you try
harder, you find
the way to factorize the state.
So I want to continue
now in explaining
different aspects
of the definition,
in particular what it means
to have a system which
has two subsystems, a and b.
Before I do that, do you have
any questions up to that point?
So we want to talk about some
standard entangled state.
And the most basic
state is a single state.
So if you have a state which
is 0 1 minus 1 0 normalized,
this is an
Einstein-Podolsky-Rosen state.
This needs some explanation.
We have often
encountered, in physics,
states which are simply
a superposition of if you
interpret 0 1 as
spin up or spin down,
you encounter that quite often.
And I want to explain
to you now what
is not an entangled state
for the reasons of using
entanglement as a resource.
So first of all, I
want to point out
this state is not
a single photon,
because we have entangled
here two qubits.
Let me just contrast it.
If you have a single
photon after beam splitter,
the single photon
after beam splitter
is in a superposition of
mode a, mode b, 0 1 minus 1 0
divided by square root 2.
But now 0 is the vacuum.
So we have not a
system which can
be decomposed into two
partial systems a and b.
You may even separate the
system and then manipulate
your single qubits individually
by putting phase shifts on
and doing other operations.
If you have this state which is
a superposition between having
a photon, not having a vacuum,
and having a vacuum state,
you cannot-- the vacuum state
itself is not a separate
system.
You cannot take the vacuum
and perform operations
on the vacuum.
So I know it has
been confusing for me
when I heard about it
for the first time.
We have, so to speak,
here an entangled mode,
but not an entangled state.
It's a singlet state.
It has some aspects
of entanglement,
but it is not the entanglement
we have defined is a resource.
So let me just repeat-- this
may be an entangled mode,
but to be in an entangled
state requires systems
where you have two parts
which you can separate.
The second comment
is we have situations
where we have two
different parts,
but they can't be
physically separated.
So part of our definition of
entanglement as a resource
is that the state must be of
two physically distinct systems.
And we want to have
parts which can
be separately addressed,
manipulated, and measured.
In other words, if you read
out one part of an EPR pair,
the other part still exists.
So that's sort of what we want.
Let me illustrate
that with examples.
For instance, in the helium
atom, you have two electrons.
And the ground state-- if I use
spin notation, is a singlet.
So that's this.
But does the ground
state of helium
fulfill our definition
of an entangled state?
Well, if you find a way
to switch off the Coulomb
potential, and then
the electrons separate
from each other, they still
maintain their spin singlet
character, then you can
take them, measure them,
take measurements,
manipulate them.
But since nobody has
come up with a good idea
how to switch off the
Coulomb potential in an atom,
you can never
separate the states.
And it is physically
impossible to address this
so the two electrons see
them separately and such.
So this state is not
entangled, because it's not--
the two systems
cannot be separated.
What is usually a good
choice for entanglement--
and this is why we discuss
it here with photons--
is you have photon states.
Photons always fly away.
Photons are in a certain
superposition state.
You can always separate them,
and take them individually.
So let's assume we have
two photons, two modes.
We have two photons--
actually, the two photons can
be in one spatial
mode, but we are now
playing with the polarization--
horizontal, vertical.
So if we have a state
with horizontal- vertical
polarization, this is a nice
entangled state of two photons.
So what did means is
that we have photon each.
One is vertical.
And one is horizontal.
But you don't know which one.
If you would just
look at one photon,
it would be 50%
horizontal, 50% vertical.
It would be completely
unpolarized,
which would be a random
state, which would require
and density matrix
for its description.
But if one photon is
horizontal, the other one
is vertical and vice versa.
So it's a pure state, but
all the pureness of the state
comes from the
entanglement and not
from what one photon
does by itself.
So these are two
photons in one mode,
and they are
polarization entangled.
Or this brings us back to our
dual [? Rail ?] single photon
states.
We have two photons, two qubits
and each is in two modes.
So our 0 state-- and
just to make sure
that you do not confuse it with
no photon, our logic 0 state,
so L means logic here--
is that the photon
is in the second mode, and
the 1 state of our logic state
means that the single
photon is in the other mode.
So we can now have
an entangled state,
which is now this 0 1 1 0 state.
But these are now
logic states, which
means that the 0 has one photon.
It has a photon in
one of the modes,
and the one has a photon
in the other mode.
So each state here
has two photons,
but then the two
photons have-- 0 1
and 1 0 are switched in the
two parts of the wave function.
And we actually saw
in the last unit
how Kerr medium and
an interferometer
can generate this state.
So yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: There
are two such states.
I mean, I will later tell
you what the four famous Bell
states are.
There is one which has
a plus sign and one
which has a minus sign.
So when we talk about
spins in singlet state,
it's often more
natural the minus sign.
Here what naturally
emerged was the plus sign,
but they are both
sort of Bell states
and therefore, they have
what Einstein-Podolsky-Rosen
introduced into it.
So tolerate both signs.
They are two different
states, but for the purpose
of the current discussion,
they have the same property--
they're maximally entangled.
Other questions?
OK, so let me point out that the
properties of entangled states
always involve two qualities.
One is the non-local character,
because we have correlation
between two subsystems which may
be together when they interact,
but then they can be separated.
So we have correlations
which happen between the two
systems which are
a distance apart.
And we later come back when we
talk about Gauss inequalities
and that we know that physics
has non-local aspects.
And secondly, if you
can separate two parts
and they interact
with the environment,
the environment may
interact with them
differently in those
two different parts.
And therefore, entangled states
are always regarded as fragile
against decoherence.
And it's a technical challenge
how do you find states?
How do you implement entangled
states which are robust?
Just to give you
one example, if you
have an entangled state which
is based on electron spin,
you may be more than
1,000 times more sensitive
to magnetic field fluctuations
in your laboratory
than if you have qubits which
are entangled states which
are based on nuclear spin.
So that's a big research
area to find states which
are less sensitive, or even
you immune against decoherence.
OK, so I've mentioned to you
that entangled states are
states which you
cannot factorize.
But now we can sort of start
playing with that definition.
And we say, OK, if you have
an entangled state which
is up-down plus down-up, but
now the contribution of down-up
has only a tiny,
little amplitude.
So it's almost a
pure state which
can be factorized with a little
bit of an extra configuration
which prevents us
from factorizing that.
I mean, that doesn't look
like good entanglement.
It looks at the
whole entanglement
of the state depends
on very small admixture
to the wave function.
And so what we
want to address now
is how can we quantify that?
How can we look at
this data and say, hey,
this is sort of not a
strongly entangled state.
It has only a weak
amount of entanglement.
So let's not forget,
entanglement is a resource.
Entanglement allows you
to do teleportation.
Entanglement allows you to
do more precise measurements.
And what I want to convey
you, if a state is only
weakly entangled,
it doesn't help
you much to achieve precision
beyond the standard limit,
effective teleportation,
and such things.
Before I introduce several
measures for entanglement,
let me talk about
entanglement purification.
It's a very nice
subject which tells you
that if you have
weakly entangled state,
you can make them
more entangled.
And actually, the
effort you have
to spend to make a weakly
entangled state more entangled
can actually act as a
measurement how entangled
was your state in
the first place.
So the purification
is introducing us
with one measurement
for entanglement,
as I just said, but it
also gives you an idea how
quantum state can
be manipulated.
Purification is also
the first example
we encounter in this
course for new insight
into quantum physics.
A lot of people thought
quantum physics, at least
non-relativistic
quantum physics that
was invented in the '20s
in the last century,
and by now we've
understood it all.
But there was an aspect
of quantum physics,
which I think nobody understood.
And this is when you have
a quantum state, which
may decohere, a quantum state
which may no longer be pure,
that you have ways
to error correction.
You have ways to get the
pure quantum state back.
And ultimately, I
mean, in the early days
when I learned
quantum physics, I
thought if you have a
quantum state, that's nice.
But if the quantum-ness
has decayed away,
you can't get it back.
But this is something we
learn now from the new methods
and new approach in
quantum information science
that you can do quantum
error correction.
You can have a stage
which has decohered
and you can get back to it.
And there is something
which-- it's not yet
that which we're discussing
today-- but in purification,
you have states which have
inferior entanglement,
but you don't need to
get stuck with that.
You can take several of
the purely entangled states
and create the maximally
entangled state out of it.
So that's what I
want to show you.
So you should look
at it as one example
that wow, it's
really cool how we
can have quantum states
with inferior quality.
And by doing quantum
operation on those states,
we get something which
is more entangled,
and therefore, if that's our
purpose, has a higher quality.
So to introduce
purification, I'm
simply mentioning what are--
for two qubits-- the standard,
maximally entangled states.
In 10 minutes or so,
we talk about how do we
measure entanglement,
and indeed, those states
will come out as being
maximally entangled.
But you already get the idea.
Maximally entangled
means they're not
factorizable and not
just by a small margin.
They may be two equal
parts of-- you always
need two equal parts
of 0 1 and 1 0,
and this state has
maximally entangled.
It's maximally non-factorizable.
So the four states which
are actually the Bell
states-- the famous Bell
basis-- are 0 1 plus minus 1 0
and 0 0 plus minus 1 1.
Just to remind you if if you
have two systems, each of them
has two states.
You can think of spin-- spin
up, down for particle one,
spin up down for particle two.
That Hilbert space
is four-dimensional.
So you need a
four-dimensional basis.
And the trivial basis is up up,
down down, up down, down up.
But what is relevant
for entangled states,
we often use the
basis of Bell states.
And this is a new
basis which spans
the four-dimensional
Hilbert space,
but each of those bases
function is maximally entangled.
OK we should correctly
normalize them.
And that state is often
called psi plus minus.
And this here is phi plus minus.
OK, so now let's get a
purely entangled state.
And let this state 0 0 plus 1 1.
But we will have
an example where
b may be very, very small.
So those states, this state
is entangled for all choices
of a and b.
So the question is now how can
we take such an arbitrary state
where a and b-- one of them
may be small, and create
a standard Bell state?
So what we have
to assume for that
is that we have a large
supply of such states.
And so let's assume we have
large supply, identical copies.
And now we want to
take two such copies.
And what I want to outline
you is the following--
you take sort of
two of your copies,
and you do a measurement.
And I will tell you what kind
of qubit operation we need,
what kind of
measurement we perform.
And then when the outcome of the
measurement is such and such,
you say-- OK let me be specific.
So if you take two
copies, we have a total
of two states with
two photons each.
And now we perform
a quantum operation
on two of the photons, and
the other two photons we leave
untouched.
So now it depends when the
measurement of the two photons
has a good outcome, we
know those other two
photons are maximally entangled.
They're in a Bell state.
If the outcome of the
measurement is bad,
it tells us the two
photons are not entangled,
and we throw them away.
So therefore, we have
a finite probability
by performing measurements
that a pair of our sample
state with the
coefficient a and b
will result into a maximally
entangled state-- in a Bell
state.
And I want to describe now
what is the protocol, what
is the procedure
to implement that.
And what we will
find-- and this is
what I think you should expect
here-- if the initial state has
very bad entanglement in the
sense that b is very small,
we will need many, many
attempts doing many measurements
on our pair of states before
we produce a Bell state.
It's probabilistic,
but the probability
to succeed in preparing a
Bell state will depend on-- we
will see-- the
product of a and b.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does the assumption
of large supply of the state
violate no-cloning in any sense?
PROFESSOR: The
question is, does it
violate the no-cloning theorem?
No, it doesn't,
otherwise I would not
say we have a large supply,
because the no-cloning theorem
is absolute.
But it simply means we
cannot have one state,
and then clone and clone
more and more copies.
Let me be specific.
If you have an
experiment which produces
a certain superposition
state, you
can just push the button on
your experiment many times,
and produce, in the
identical create,
as many states as you want.
If you have spin-up
state-- well,
this is now for two photons,
but if you have a spin-up state,
you can make as
many copies as you
want of the state which has
been rotated by a certain angle.
So therefore, in
state preparation,
by going through
the exact procedure,
we can just create as many
copies of a state we want.
The no-cloning [INAUDIBLE]
meant the following--
I give you one state
which may be a spin which
has been rotated
at a certain angle.
You know nothing
about the state.
And now you should try
to make a copy out of it.
And the answer is you can't,
because any measurement you do
is-- if the particle
were spin up
and you would measure
spin up or speed down,
you could say I got spin up.
Now I produce 10
spin up particles.
But you don't know
along which axis
the spin has been prepared.
So unless you know which axis
the spin has been oriented,
and if you choose another axis,
you have irreversibly lost
information which
cannot be retrieved.
I don't know if it
helps you, but if you
have a certain state, and
you're going to measure it
without destroying it, you
need a quantum non-demolition
measurement.
If you're in energy eigenstate,
you can measure energy.
If you're in a spin eigenstate
which points along Z,
you can measure the direction
of the spin in the Z direction
without destroying it.
So if you can do a quantum
non-demolition measurement
on a state, you could clone it.
But that violates the assumption
that if I give you an arbitrary
state, you do not know
by definition what kind
of measurement is a
non-demolition measurement.
You just take your
chance, you try
to take a Stern-Gerlach
experiment, separate the spins
in the Z component,
and then it turns out
I gave you a state which
is polarized along x.
So that's a subtle, but
important difference.
Other questions?
So we take two copies and
let's bring in Alice and Bob.
So the first photon we
associate with Alice.
And the second photon
is associated with Bob.
So if you take two
copies-- we have now
is an Hilbert space, a
four-dimensional Hilbert
space, a direct product.
And if you just take
the state and calculate
the direct product, you get four
terms-- 0 0 1 1, 0 0 1 1, 1 1
0 0, and 1 1 1 1.
And the coefficients
are given here.
Let me just underline
that it if you
think we have some state
with some entanglement,
and we separate the
system, one goes to Alice
and one goes to Bob.
So the one which Alice has
is the first part of it
those states.
And Bob has the other part.
So the protocol is now that
Alice and Bob first, they're
not doing a measurement.
They're not reading
out the system.
They perform a
unitary operation.
And what Alice and
Bob have formed
is the controlled NOT
operation on the two qubits.
Let me just write it
down and then explain it.
Perform what is called the
controlled NOT or CNOT gate.
And I've explained before
in the last section how
the controlled NOT
can be performed
using a non-linear
Mach-Zehnder interferometer.
So Bob and Alice both
run their two photons
with the non-linear
Mach-Zehnder interferometer.
So what is a controlled NOT?
Let me remind you.
If you have two qubits, the
first one is the control.
If the control is 1,
you flip the second one.
If the control is 0, you do
nothing to the second one.
So the controlled
CNOT transforms.
So since the first qubit
is the control qubit, out
of those four combinations,
the controlled NOT only
does something if Alice's
controls and Bob's controls
is 1, and then the
second bit is flipped.
If Alice's and Bob's
controls are 0,
they do nothing
to the second bit.
So therefore, the 1 1 0
is transformed into 1 1 1,
and the 1 1 1 1 is
transformed into 1 1 0 0.
So that's the first operation.
Let me just indicate it.
So what has happened here, the
0 0 has been flipped into 1 1
and the 1 1 has been
flipped into 0 0.
That's the first step.
The second step is
that now Alice and Bob
measure their target qubit.
What does that mean?
We have a controlled
NOT operation.
In the controlled
NOT operation, we
have the first one
is the control qubit.
The second one is the
target of the operation.
So in our, the way
how we write it,
Alice's target is
the third in line,
and Bob is the fourth in line.
So now Alice and Bob
measure the target qubits.
Let me just be specific.
So Alice has number
one and number three.
Bob has number two and
four, and the target qubits
are the third and fourth.
So what is the probability that
Alice and Bob measure both 1 1,
that they both find
the target qubit of 1?
Well, it is this one
and it is this one
where the controlled
NOT has flipped it.
So one has the probability
a squared b squared.
The other one has probability
So with probability 2 a
squared b squared-- well,
let's allow a and
b to be complex.
They obtain 1 and 1.
So in this case, what
is left is here 0 0.
What is here left is 1 1.
You may just need
an intermediate line
to write down what the state
is after the measurement.
But if you read it
off here, you find
that when they
obtain 1 1 1, that
implies the post measurement
state is then 0 0 plus 1 1
divided by square of 2, and
this is one of our Bell states.
So what we had is we had
a system of four photons
after a qubit operation,
the controlled NOT.
Alice and Bob do a measurement
together on two of the photons.
Collins.
And if the outcome of
this measurement is 1 1,
the rest of the system
is in the Bell state.
So we assume that
Alice and Bob have
a large supply of those copies.
So let's assume that they
start with n copies of psi.
And then, because the
probability is m over n,
they successfully obtain m
copies of the Bell state.
And the question is,
what is the probability
in the limit of
a large ensemble.
And we will see in a few
moments that this is actually
a measurement of how entangled
the original space is.
Any questions
about purification?
Well, then let's
measure entanglement.
The basic idea
here is that if you
have a state up/down plus
down/up, it's a pure state.
But this pure state
has a correlation
between the two subsystems.
And the idea is
now entanglement is
that there is a correlation
between the two subsystems.
And you can say well,
it would be a good way
to characterize entanglement if
I only look at one subsystem.
In this case, you
look at one subsystem,
and you would just randomly
see spin up, spin down.
Spin up spin down is described
by the unity density matrix,
which is, therefore, the
most random state on earth.
So if you have a pure state and
you only look at one subsystem,
the more random
the subsystem is,
the more the pureness
of the initial state
comes from correlations,
comes what is entanglement.
So therefore, what I
want to introduce now
as a measure of entanglement is
that we take the total system
and then we perform
the partial trace.
We only look at one subsystem.
And the purer the subsystem
is, the less entangled
it is, because in
the ultimate limit
that our system factorizes into
two pure states, when we look
at the subsystem, we
still have a pure state.
So the purity of the subsystem
in terms of pure state
is now a measure
of entanglement.
The purer the subsystem is,
the less entangled it was.
So the basic idea here
is entanglement is
related to correlations.
And if you take half
of a Bell state--
so if two particles which
are an EPR pair and we
take half of it-- then half
of it is completely random.
So let me illustrate that.
So if you take one
half of-- let's just
take one of the Bell
states, phi plus,
which was the superposition
of 0 0 plus 1 1.
So let me be specific, because
we need it for the definition.
We describe this ensemble of
this system in a pure EPR state
by a density matrix.
The density matrix
is nothing else
than you take your total system.
So this is now the
density matrix.
So in our case, psi a
b is just the state.
And now we describe
the subsystem
by performing a
partial trace on rho.
The partial trace is
over the system b.
And that means we take all
eigenfunctions k b of state b,
sum over all k's, and
this is our partial trace.
So therefore, we would take
our statistical operator
from the line above, and
perform the partial trace
where those states are
the state 0 and 1 of b.
So these are the states of b.
So when you do that,
you just insert that.
You find that what
you get is 1/2.
a has been traced out,
so b has been traced out.
And what we obtain for a is
just from the two terms above.
This gives that,
and this gives that.
And you immediately realize that
this is 1/2 times the identity
matrix.
So therefore, we
have shown that this
is a completely random state.
So now we can characterize
the randomness
of the partial trace of the
density operator obtained
by performing the partial trace
with the standard von Neumann
entropy.
As a reminder, the
von Neumann entropy
for statistical operator rho
is defined as the expectation
value of rho log rho, where we
take the logarithm with respect
to the base 2.
So this is the trace
of rho log rho.
Or if we use the
eigenvalues of rho,
we multiply eigenvalues with the
logarithm of the eigenvalues.
So for a pure state,
the entropy is 0,
because a pure state has
one eigenvalue, which is 1,
and the log of 1 is 0, so
we get 0 for pure state.
For completely
mixed state, we're
talking about a state which
has two dimensions, so it
can be up and down.
A completely unique state has
probabilities of 1/2 each.
And then we say the entropy
of this state is one,
or we call it one bit.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: About the
volume [INAUDIBLE]
expectation of rho
log rho is called
a trace [INAUDIBLE] expectation
of log rho, expectation
of [INAUDIBLE] trace of the
operator times density matrix.
PROFESSOR: OK, so this
is just a reminder
of how we measure entropy
of density matrix.
And now we apply
it to entanglement.
We define now the entanglement
for the entanglement
e over state psi a b to be
the entropy of the density
matrix for system a after
tracing out system b.
And for pure state, this is-- it
doesn't matter whether we trace
out a or b if you start
with a pure state.
The entanglement, the entropy
of the statistical operator
rho a and rho b are the same.
I tried for a
moment to prove it.
I saw it quoted somewhere.
I didn't succeed
in a split second,
so either I
overlooked something,
or it's a little bit more
involved to show that.
So therefore, to
use the inverts,
our definition says that the
entropy, so the entanglement,
is nothing else than the entropy
of the reduced density matrix.
And we immediately see if
we have any of the four Bell
states, by performing the
partial trace over one qubit,
we obtain the identity matrix.
So therefore, the entropy
of all the Bell states is 1.
Let me state without
proof-- when we come back
to the purification
scheme the result
is that the probability or
the optimum probability--
if you do stupid
measurements on your states,
of course you get nothing.
But the optimum strategy to
create pure Bell states out
of your reservoir of
poorly entangled states--
so for an optimum strategy, the
success probability m over n
actually turns out to be
not a different measure
of entanglement.
It is the entanglement
which we have just
defined through the entropy
of the partial trace.
So therefore-- and I
think this is nicely
illustrated with the
purification scheme--
entanglement is a real resource.
When you have better
entanglement to start with,
then you can get more copies.
You can get more
pure Bell states
out of your supply of
poorly entangled states.
So therefore, you lose
more if your states are not
fully entangled.
You lose more of them,
and therefore, the success
of the purification
scheme makes it clear
how entanglement is a resource.
If you have entanglement,
it's precious.
You had to do
something to get it.
I didn't point out
entanglement is not
something which one number
characterize it, it's all.
We introduced to you
already another measurement
of entanglement through
the Schmidt number,
which was in
homework number two.
And usually when you
have different measures
for entanglement, they're
not one to one related.
It seems that, similarly when
we measured non-classic light,
we had a G2 function.
We had [INAUDIBLE]
bunching, antibunching.
We have negative
quasi probabilities.
And it's often clear
that one system which
is truly non-classical,
fulfills all the criteria,
but how the quantitative
measurements are related
to each other is really subtle.
In the case of entanglement,
for a long time it
has even been a big
question in research--
if you have an
arbitrary density matrix
with a complicated
many-body system,
how can you even characterize
the entanglement?
We are focusing
here on pure states
where things are fairly simple.
But in the general situation
of a many-body system,
it can be quite challenging
just define and measure
entanglement.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: If you have a
general [INAUDIBLE] that's
not necessarily a
pure state, can you
show that it's
always the reduced
trace of the bigger [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Say again, if I
have a general state which is--
AUDIENCE: You have a subsystem--
let's say you have two spins,
and then you have
a density matrix
for the first-- or actually just
to say that you have one spin
and you have a density
matrix for that single spin,
it's a matrix, not
necessarily a pure state.
Let's say it's a mixed state.
Then you can introduce
a fake second spin
and show that this matrix is the
trace of a matrix [INAUDIBLE]
and maybe just put that one in
a pure state and do some stuff,
do some calculations
more easily.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
If you have a
density matrix, you
can always regard it as a
partial trace of a bigger
system.
That means you always represent
your state as a pure state,
but it is entangled
with a bigger system.
However, what the big system
is, is by no means unique.
I'm missing the
technical word-- it's
called unraveling
the density matrix.
You can always represent the
density matrix written down
in forms of pure state.
But this unraveling of
the density matrix-- no,
actually, its related.
When I said yes, I thought
about the unraveling
of the density matrix.
You can always write
down a density matrix
as a mixture of pure states,
but which are the pure states
is not unique.
So when you say my
density matrix is
half of the atoms are spin
up and half of the atoms
are spin down, somebody else
would say, no, that's not true.
Half of the atoms are spin
[INAUDIBLE] and spin x
and some are in spin minus
x, and those representations
are equivalent.
So I was just thinking of that
as to write down the density
matrix in the pure state basis.
But you are asking about--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] what
he's asking about [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Somehow, but
I was thinking of that,
but I think the answer
to your question is yes.
So you said, you confirmed that.
AUDIENCE: Yes, but
I am forgetting
the name of the theorem here.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it just
purification again?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
related to purification.
You can prove that you're
using purification.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Using
purification [INAUDIBLE]
but I'm completely forgetting
the names of [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: But wait.
We've talked here
about-- just to be clear,
we've talked here about
purification of a pure state.
We started with a
pure state and we
purified it to be a Bell state
by doing certain measurements.
So we've not talked here
about density matrices,
but it sounds very plausible
that you can always
construct a bigger system.
But I should look it up and
see if there is an exact proof.
It's-- intuitively
it sounds correct.
Other questions?
OK, so we have discussed the
definition of entangled state.
We've talked about purification
of entangled states
and how to measure it.
I want to talk now
about how we can
create entangled
states for atoms.
Maybe let me say the following--
so by now we are convinced.
Entangled states are great,
and we want to create them.
And for photons, I showed you
that some simple element--
beam splitters, Kerr medium--
can create entanglement.
It's much harder to
do that with atoms.
Now, we want to
do it with atoms,
because atoms-- in
contrast to light-- they're
pretty much staying still,
whereas photons always
move at the speed of light.
And the only way to
make photons stand still
is you put them in a
cavity and then they
bounce back and forth.
But even in super cavities
with the highest reflectivity
mirror, you get-- what are
the longest ring-down times
you get-- fraction of
a second, milliseconds,
depending kind of
in which domain
you work-- microwave
domain, optical domain.
Whereas atoms, you can hold onto
your qubits for a long time.
So therefore, if you
want to use entanglement
as a resource for
certain protocols,
you want to have entangled atoms
where the entanglement would
like for a long time.
So the question
is now for atoms,
we do not have perfect beam
splitters and perfect Kerr
mediums.
Also, we can control
interactions between atoms
for [INAUDIBLE] using
VSEPR resonances,
but that's another story.
But now let me ask a question,
how do we entangle atoms?
And I want to first
show you that if you
had the right system,
things can be fairly simple.
This is a suggestion which
was made almost 20 years ago,
and it goes like
follows-- if you
have a diatomic molecule
of two identical atoms,
in this case
mercury, and mercury
doesn't have-- this molecule
doesn't have any electron spin,
but mercury has a nuclear spin.
And if you now photo-dissociate
mercury and two mercury atoms
fly away, then you have
separated a spin singlet
into two parts.
And now you have
created the Bell state
up/down minus down/up.
So you could say this is sort
of the example-- this realizes
very closely the example I
gave you with the helium atom,
where I said you have an
electron in spin up and spin
down, but there was no way
to separate the electrons.
Therefore, you can say it is a
state which has entanglement,
but it's not entanglement
as a resource.
But right now, here
it becomes a resource
once you have found a
method to separate the two
parts of the wave function that
you can give one to Alice, give
one to Bob, and they can
perform the operations on it.
Well, if it looks so
simple, why don't we
have entangled atoms everywhere?
This experiment has been
suggested 20 years ago,
but nobody has done it,
or some several groups
have worked on it.
You need a molecule
with suitable states.
You don't want any electron
spin which interferes with that.
All you want to have
is two nuclear spins.
You want a singlet state here.
So those requirements
are not easily fulfilled
with real atoms.
Of course we liked-- and also
who wants to work with mercury?
Mercury has transitions
in the ultraviolet.
I think there's only one
group in the world who
has operated a magneto
optic trap with mercury.
So it's not your tabletop atom.
So therefore, let's
now talk about a method
how we can entangle
atoms by using light.
So if you take
atoms, maybe we can
use the light which
has been emitted
from the atoms, performing
measurement on the light,
and then depending on the
outcome of the measurement,
we know the atoms are entangled.
So Professor [? Swann ?] calls
this the poor man's entangler.
I don't know why poor man's.
You still need quite a
bit of equipment to do it.
But at least it seems
the poor man's solution
if you can't make the
above experiment work.
So this addresses
a question that,
just for technical
reasons matter
is more difficult to entangle.
Whereas photons are easy.
Yeah so you can say
the idea is related
to the purification scheme.
We can't take a system of two
atoms, atom one and atom two
which are unentangled, and we
shine some laser light on them,
excite them.
Then they emit photons.
So all we can do
is-- we can only
talk to the atoms
with the photons.
So the only thing
we can do now is
we can measure the two photons.
And then the situation will be
similar as in the purification
scheme, where Alice and
Bob did a measurement.
If Alice and Bob said both
of our target qubits are one,
then what was left behind was
in a pure, entangled Bell state.
And similarly, what you want to
do here is we have two atoms.
There was nothing special about
them but they scatter light.
And if you now perform a
measurement on the photons
and the outcome of the
measurement is positive,
then we know for sure what has
been left behind is entangled.
That's the idea.
So it shares with the
purification scheme
that it is a probabilistic
entanglement.
You run your
experiment many times.
You do a measurement.
If the measurement
is positive, you
say now I have an
entangled state.
And maybe then you can move on
to measure the entanglement.
You can move on to do
teleportation, other things you
want to do with
entangled states.
But if your measurements
says no, bad luck.
The probability hasn't
worked out this time.
You just press a button
again, scatter light
again of your two atoms
and/or your two ions
and hope that the next
outcome is positive.
So the idea is we
want to introduce now
a probabilistic method.
It's based on two
atoms emitting light.
And the result is with
a certain probability
that we get entangled atoms.
Let me just scroll down and
show you one thing I want to--
When I prepare the notes and
everything is clear to me,
but then I want to explain
it to you and say hey,
I have to motivate you.
If I just go
through a few lines,
you wonder what it leads to.
So let me maybe first
give you the explanation
I would have given you
a little bit later.
What is an entangled
state is if the atoms are
in maybe one of two ground
states-- one atom is in one
ground state, the other
one is in the other one,
or it is flipped.
So we know one atom is
in the ground state one.
One atom is in the
ground state two,
but we don't know
which one is in which.
It is in the
superposition state.
So what you need
now in this scheme
is the following-- if
the atoms scatter light,
they can go to two
different ground states.
And we know to
which ground state
they have gone, because
due to selection rules,
they reach one ground state
with polarization one.
They reach one ground state
with polarization two.
So therefore, when we had
two atoms, they emit light
and we would measure the
polarization of the light,
we would know in
which state they are.
But if you know atom
1 is in state 1,
and atom 2 is in state
2, this is not entangled.
So what we have to do is when
the two atoms have emitted
photons, we have to mix the
photon at the beam splitter.
And after the beam
splitter, when
we measure that the
photon is polarized,
we know that one of the atoms
is in one of the ground states,
but we don't know which.
So therefore, we can now
use-- the photon carries
through the polarization the
information in which ground
state the atom is.
But now we have to perform
operations to the photons
that for fundamental
reasons, fundamental quantum
measurement, we know there
is one photon in one state,
but we have no way
to ever figure out
which atom has
emitted the photon.
So that's the idea,
and the protocol
I want to show you now is what
do we have to do to the two
photons to make sure
that we never know,
that we can't find out which
atom has emitted the photon.
And we have to do little
bit more tricks also
to make sure that when we do
a measurement on the photon,
we know the atoms are
in the Bell state.
Questions about that?
So therefore, we
need a beam splitter.
So we can come back to
what we have already
introduced in the last section.
So each atom will emit a photon.
And I will actually show
you at the end of the class
that people have
entangled with that scheme
two ions which were in
two different ion traps.
So you have two distance atoms.
They emit light, and after
the measurement process,
you know they are entangled.
And that's pretty cool.
So the situation how we do it is
we have two photons which come.
But the first thing
we have to make sure
is we have to
scramble the photons.
We have to make sure
that we can't find out
from which atom the
photon has come,
and this is done with
the beam splitter.
So there is one aspect
of beam splitters
and two photons which have
to explain to you now.
And this is this famous
HUM, Hong-Ou-Mandel.
This is the Hong-Ou-Mandel
interference.
It's a very famous
effect, and it's actually
very, very special.
So let me explain
what happens when
we have two photons
in the same state--
two identical photons, same
frequency, same polarization--
coming to a beam splitter.
So we have already
all the tools.
So we have a beam
splitter characterized
by this angle theta, which
through cosine theta,
sine theta determines what
the beam splitter is doing.
And all we want to do is we
apply it now to the state 1 1.
So what we will find is
that there is a probability
to get one photon each.
Then there is a probability to
get two photons in one output.
And it will actually
be the same probability
with a minus sign in the
amplitude to get 0 2.
And the matrix which acts
on each of the photons
has cosines and sines.
So what we get is products
of trigonometric functions.
And here for getting
two photons in one arm,
it's square root 2,
cosine theta, sine theta.
And the spectacular
thing here is
what happens when we have
a balanced beam splitter.
If you have the
50-50 beam splitter--
and this is called the
Hong-Ou-Mandel interference,
you have the situation where
you have a beam splitter,
you have one photon,
you have two photons.
And it is absolutely
impossible that afterwards, you
have one photon in each arm.
So you send two photons
on a beam splitter,
and after the beam
splitter is, you
have either two photons
coming out here,
or two photons coming out there.
You can say it's Poissonic
stimulation photons and bosons.
That all plays a role.
If one photon goes one path,
the other photons follow suit.
This is now very powerful,
because it already
happens, of course, when the
two photons are identical.
We had to use in this
formalism the photon is
in the same mode on each part.
But that means now
the following--
if you set up photo
detectors here,
and each photon
detector makes click,
you know you had
one photon each.
And that tells you that the two
photons were not identical--
for instance, because they
have different polarizations.
So if you want to
now, with the atoms,
get a Bell state, where
atoms decay-- one atom
decays to state
one, one atom decays
to state two-- the
signature of that
would be that we
have one atom each.
And if you do it right, one atom
each is an ingredient for 1 2
plus 2 1 for Bell state.
We can detect that we have one
photon each because at such
a beam splitter, it's
only in this situation
that we can get one photon
after each beam splitter
if we start with two
non-identical photons.
Of course, by the way,
experimentally there are quite
some challenges, even if
you have identical photons
of the same polarization, if
they arrive as a nanosecond
pulse, and they don't arrive
exactly at the same time
at the beam splitter, then
you first split one photon,
and then the next photon,
and the two photons cannot
influence each other.
So there are a lot of
experimental requirements
to realize this
ideal experiment.
So as I was preparing
for today's class,
I actually saw a paper which
just came out in "Science."
So in this month's
"Science" they
discussed the Hong-Ou-Mandel
interference experiment
with fermions.
So let me just
explain what happens.
OK, now it fits.
So if you have two
identical photons,
if you have two particles which
impinge on the beam splitter--
they are the two input beams
for the beam splitter--
you would say you have
four different outcomes.
One is both come out
here, both come out here.
Or they are both
reflected, or they are both
transmitted through.
And what happens is bosons--
as I just pointed out--
bosons characterized by
photons can only do that.
Identical photons
want two bunch up.
They appear in pairs-- 50%
left output, 50% right output.
Well, for fermions, they
just do the opposite.
For fermions, you will
always get one particle each.
You may immediately,
of course, explain it
with the Pauli Exclusion
Principle, which does not
allow two particles to
be in the same state
after the beam splitter.
And you should contrast it
with classical particles.
When you have two
classical particles,
you will actually find that all
of those four possibilities,
each of them has
a 25% probability.
So it was a major
experiment which
was featured in "Science"
when people realized
that with electrons,
they created electrons
in a semiconductor
structure, and showed
through some
statistical measurement
that this was the
physics which happened.
The measurement they did
is, I forgot details--
if you have bosons and you get
either two here or two there,
you have more fluctuations in
your system than for fermions.
And they conclusively
showed that they
had realized the Hong-Ou-Mandel
interference for fermions.
I think we have to stop.
Let me just add one more
thing and then we are done.
So this Hong-Ou-Mandel
interference
is at the heart of how
perform the measurement which
is ultimately
entangling the atoms.
But we need one more element.
We need sort of to scramble
the photons in one more way,
and this is by adding circular
polarizers at the input.
So we assume for now
that we start out
with linear polarization
in those states.
And here is our beam splitter.
Here is mode a and mode
be, which we detect.
And before we measure
this Hong interference,
we put in quarter-wave
plates which
provide circular polarization.
If you start with linearly
polarized light-- we
put in a polarizer-- after
the circular polarizer,
we have this linear
superposition
of horizontal and
vertical at mode one,
and we have linear
polarization-- superposition
of linear polarization
in mode two.
So this is a situation at the
input of the beam splitter.
And if we expand it,
we have probabilities
where the polarization
is different,
and where the
polarization is the same.
So we have two detectors here.
And if both detectors
click, then we
know that the input
to the interferometer
was not H H nor V V,
because in that case,
the Hong-Ou-Mandel interference
would have directed
both photons to one
output, and we would not
have obtained clicks from both.
So therefore, when
both detectors click,
we know that the quantum state
before the interferometer--
before the beam splitter-- was
H V or V H-- or, of course,
in another basis, one of those.
And this is sort of
the ingredient, which
I will show you on
Wednesday, which
can lead to probabilistic
entanglement of atoms.
Any questions?
OK, one announcement-- we
post this week's homework
assignment later today.
It will be due in a week.
See you on Wednesday.